[Music]
the first fireplaces were strictly
functional for heating the home cooking
meals and warming water for bathing over
time fireplaces appeared in other rooms
of the house and acquired aesthetic
features such as wood stone or tile work
this ceramic fireplace is a heritage
model inspired by fireplaces of the late
19th and early 20th century certain
tiles are exact replicas of originals at
the ceramic factory they mix water with
clay feldspar and silica in a pug mill
together these formulate a clay blend
once the mix is the right consistency
the operator presses a button and the
mill switches to extrusion mode
this forces the clay blend through a
mantle shaped die and produces a 10 to
15 inch long extruded mantelpiece they
trim the piece with a cutting wire to
the precise length required
they use this extrusion method for
making longer pieces if they need
shorter ones they often cast them
individually in a mold when casting they
add significantly more water to the clay
blend to produce a liquid clay called
slip they pour the slip into a plaster
mold the porous plaster gradually
absorbs most of the water leaving a
layer of clay about six millimeters
thick on the walls of the mantle shaped
cavity after a few hours they pour out
the excess slip and open the mold to
extract the cast mantle piece once the
clay becomes firm enough to handle they
carefully trim off the excess around the
opening in the mold then they gently
smooth down the seam along the junction
between the two halves of the mold on
the opposite side of the pour hole they
cut out a matching hole this will help
the clay dry faster by enabling air to
flow through the inside of the piece
to compensate for shrinkage the molds
and extrusion dyes are designed 11
percent larger than the size of the
finished piece clay shrinks as it dries
to make the fireplaces ceramic tiles
they produce a rubber mold of two
adjoining tiles and place it inside a
metal casing they also include a relief
system to help with extraction they fill
the casing with an exceptionally strong
type of plaster it sets in about half an
hour taking on the shape of the rubber
mold this plaster casting is the dye
they'll now use to produce the tiles
they mount the dye on what's known as a
ram press because it literally Rams a
block of clay in the dye and compresses
it with 30 tons of pressure
the tile dye is also 11% larger than the
final size to compensate for shrinkage
during drying and firing they remove
excess clay and send it back to the pug
mill to be recycled
then they position a board under the die
and activate the relief system which
extracts the clay with a blast of
compressed air
[Music]
they trim off the excess clay
once dry the tiles and mantelpieces are
ready to be glazed glaze is a chemical
formula containing finely ground silica
combined with different combinations of
metallic elements to produce specific
colors they use a spray gun to apply
glaze to the mantles and a tube tip
applicator to glaze the tiles
[Music]
the tile design has raised borders
between its components these are called
cuenca lines they prevent the different
color glazes from flowing into each
other the glazed mantelpiece and titles
now going to a gas-fired kiln for 12 to
14 hours the high temperature 2100
degrees Fahrenheit triggers chemical
reactions which harden and strengthen
the pieces the Clay's mineral
composition transforms into a completely
new configuration of crystals and glass
as for the glaze its precise formulation
of metallic elements produces a specific
color and the silica melts into a glass
surface the ceramics are now smooth and
shiny and ready to transform an
otherwise ordinary fireplace into a work
of art